it's great to be joined today by dr.
Nathalie Marichal who is a senior
research analyst at ranking digital
rights where she studies the impact of
information and communication company's
business practices on Human Rights today
we're going to talk a little bit about
online advertising targeted advertising
maybe to start with I think a lot of
people in our audience who use the
Internet have a sense of what we mean by
targeted ads but what's a more general
overview of the different ways in which
targeted ads can exist thanks David so
when I was growing up and presumably
when you were growing up David we saw a
lot of advertising on TV and newspapers
and magazines on Billboard's and the way
that these ads were selected way that
brands decided what ad to place where
was based on the context in which it
would be seen so if you were driving
through an area that's near a shopping
mall you would see billboards for that
shopping mall or if you were in LA you
would see a lot of for your
consideration award show
types of ads billboard ads that you
wouldn't see in some other parts of the
country for example and so when the
internet took off the big internet
companies and news media organizations
websites kind of copied the same model
at first let's say okay well this is a
story about golf so the people who are
reading it are probably interested in
golf so let's show them some ads for
golf clubs and so on and then what
happened gradually in the late 90s and
early 2000s is that a bunch of company
is starting with Google realized that
because the Internet is a two-way
communication channel they actually knew
a lot about the people who were visiting
their sites and what other sites they
had visited and who they were and what
they were interested in so that they
could match the ads not just to the
content that the person was seeking out
in that moment but to other interests
and characteristics that the companies
knew or thought that they knew about the
person based on all the other data that
they had about them so that's why when
you look for something let's say a type
of shoe one day on
one device that adds for similar pairs
of shoes may be through different
vendors are gonna follow you around the
internet across different browsers and
different devices for any number of days
now there are there's a wide spectrum of
sort of opinion as to whether this is a
good thing a bad thing an immoral thing
an immoral thing which would be a sort
of different different assessment but a
common refrain that I hear not only from
people who are working in the industry
but also from people who sort of claim
to just be objective analyzers of modern
advertising they say there's going to be
advertising people aren't willing to pay
for all content on the internet and the
way that they can pay for it without
paying for it with cash is by looking at
ads or being subjected to ads isn't
everybody better off if the ads are
targeted to the interests of the
individual that's the the kind of
talking point that is a common refrain
how would we start to or might we start
to break that apart into its component
pieces to consider whether it's actually
such a win-win right so that's a really
good point and I think it's likely that
that advertising in some form is is here
to stay as you say there's somebody has
to pay for for content to be produced
and it does seem that the market isn't
going to support the full cost of
producing data or you know things that
you read things that you watch think
other kinds of entertainment or
information online at the same time we
have to think really carefully about
what it is they were giving up when
we're surrendering our privacy by
agreeing that anyone who has the
technical capacity to can track whatever
you do on the Internet
combine that with any other data sources
that they can acquire about you from
credit card companies banks your cell
phone provider your ISP anywhere else
and just say that you can do whatever
you want within that debt with that data
as long as you can make it happen
right I think there have to be some kind
of limits so for example there's
story yesterday that came out in the
verge about how several cellphone
companies in the US including t-mobile
were actually selling really really
detailed location data about their
customers to all kinds of data
aggregators and who were then able to
recreate exactly what people do day to
day where they go what they do when
they're there and create like these
whole patterns of life to use kind of a
spy jargon to figure out what everybody
is doing and then figure out exactly how
to insert specific ads into that
person's day in a way that feels really
creepy and invasive to a lot of people
so I think it's you have to think
carefully about what kind of data is
allowed to be collected about people in
what circumstances and and I think in
that case consent is really important
because most of this collection happens
without people even knowing about it
right so yeah along those lines
can you talk a little bit about the
difference between opting in and opting
out when it comes to this type of
information gathering right so when
you're opting in it means that by
default people can do can it can assume
that they are not being tracked unless a
notification comes up prominently and
says do you consent to being trapped for
this or do you or do you consent to
having this data about you collected in
this context and this is why we this is
why we the the website for example once
and what we might use it for and I think
for the most part that's completely fine
but then there's the assumption of
opt-out which is that you have to assume
that you're being tracked at all times
and that maybe if you dig deep enough
you can find a setting to opt out of
that but a lot of times that's only
partially effective because every time
you come back to the site or you reboot
the app or what have you you have to
opt-out again so it's it's one of those
things where it's become if the
companies we're tracking you are trying
so hard to do it without your knowledge
isn't that a little fishy well let's
explore that because you know I think
that we could have a reasonable
disagreement as to where the line should
be when it comes to what information
should or shouldn't be opt in opt out
nope no question that that's a
legitimate conversation but where I want
to go with you next is that this is not
just about products or services or web
hosting or sneakers or whatever the case
may be we saw how the same data that a
sneaker company can use to target people
on facebook was used by foreign powers
to try to influence the 2016 election as
one example can you talk a little bit
about the non sort of innocuous let's
target clothing and grocery order
services to people and talk about the
ways in which authoritarianism in
different places around the world is
sort of fueled by this technology that's
right so what's really important to
understand is that this digital
infrastructure that makes target
advertising possible is at its core an
infrastructure of influence right the
point of advertising is to influence
people to do something or not do
something and that same infrastructure
can be used just as easily to sell
sneakers as you say as it can to sell
white supremacy to propagate hate speech
to propagate disinformation and this can
beat us for information like giving
incorrect facts to minority and
low-income voters to tell them that
Election Day is actually on Wednesday
rather than Tuesday we saw that
happening in the last election in the US
it can be spreading lies about entire
ethnic groups and encouraging people to
harm them and that's something that's
been going on in Myanmar notably via
Facebook and it seems to me that it's
very difficult to to draw a really clear
consistent line that is actually
enforceable about what the the benign or
even positive uses of this
infrastructure is versus what the what
the harmful uses are and to their credit
companies like Facebook and Google are
trying very hard to draw that line but
as I think we're starting to see the the
line itself is impossible to draw and
enforcing it is even more difficult yeah
I mean I guess there's sort of two
directions we could go one is would laws
against the ways in which the
information has been used even be
effective if it's for example a foreign
power trying to influence an American
election because they're not even in the
United States we've seen even with some
of the indictments that have been handed
down in the robert muller investigation
that they are of people who are not in
the u.s. it's unclear whether they
there's even any mechanism to bring them
to justice so that's sort of question
one which is like a kind of a
jurisdictional question question two
would be a business regulatory question
as to whether what exactly is the
mechanism by which the government can
say what can and cannot be done down to
this degree
feel free to address either or both of
those questions sure so I think you make
a really good point with this question
about jurisdiction and I think that's
what makes regulating a lot of things in
the Internet age incredibly difficult
and I think that's a really strong
reason of why the current efforts to
draw this line as as well intentioned as
they are are probably not going to be
very successful as as hard as people are
working to make them work what I do
think is more likely to have an impact
is regulations like the European GDP are
or the California Privacy Act that's due
to come into force next year in 2020
that strictly regulate what kinds of
information companies and other entities
can collect in the first place how they
can be used when and how consent has to
be sought from the person whose
information we're talking about and then
maintaining the right for for that
person to find out what information is
held about them have it corrected if
it's wrong or even asked for have it
deleted and make it very clear that
people maintain
in the right to control the information
that circulates about them throughout
this this infrastructure of influence
that that exists outside of our eyesight
is this politically viable in the sense
not from what it is that the end-user
would prefer or tolerate but just sort
of pragmatically thinking about the
influence that the companies that are
doing this have on our elected officials
both Democratic and Republican you know
if there's anything I've learned that
past two years is to not make any not
make any guesses about what's going to
happen next in the world of American
politics fair enough no but I guess I
mean so aside from predicting what would
happen just having an understanding of
the way in which companies like Google
and Facebook and Apple are so much a
part of the conversation around how they
should be regulated without making any
prediction would you grant that the
infrastructure that's in place is one
that is not particularly favorable to
our elected officials merely making
policy that reflects the desire of the
people and that the lobbying dot-com
industrial complex is one that is
powerful I think we would accept I mean
I think I think your analysis is is
accurate for sure but at the same time I
think there's a great danger here in
giving up the fight before we even start
it yes and just accepting certain things
as inevitable without actually trying to
change them yeah I mean I think if
anything what the last you know several
decades 200 years of activism have told
us is if you concede as inevitable
something you've definitely lost and if
you don't then at least it's a
conversation that you can fight over
that's right we've been speaking with
dr. Natalie Marichal who is a senior
research analyst at ranking digital
rights Natalie thank you so much for
talking to me today about this my
pleasure thanks for having me